elle est née un 8 mars un signe du
destin diront certains mon invité nous a
fait voir les barbecues sous un autre
jour et c'est sa force elle arrive à
imposer ses thèmes dans le débat public
bike
[Musique]
bonjour Sandrine Rousseau bonjour alors
votre première télévision je crois en
tout cas vous n'avez pas fait en tant
que femme politique mais en tant que
romancière autrice d'un roman policier
très exactement c'était en 2007 pour un
polar intitulé épluchures à la Lilloise
c'est un homme qui est retrouvé mort et
une partie du Tor s'arracher va éplucher
et cet homme est entouré de femmes dans
sa vie et donc il faut savoir qui a eu
cette idée saugrenue les plus chers il y
a 4 ans exacerbé par un chef elle se
vend la nuit avec des mots moi j'ai
commencé à écrire quand la coupe a été
trop pleine c'est une caricature d'un de
mes chefs une caricature parce que en
fait le soir c'était un peu comme une
poupée vaudouge
[Musique]
je suis planté des aiguilles
[Rires]
saugrenue découcher cet homme sinon vous
me fait rire parce que c'est extrait a
mis encore toutes les
ça tourne en boucle sur internet ça fait
ça crée une panique morale alors que
c'est un livre qui est complètement
humoristique il faut le lire c'est rien
n'est sérieux là-dedans mais ça y est
c'est la panique morale de toute façon
dès que je parle il y a une panique
morale donc rassurez-vous chez personne
ce qui m'intéresse dans cette archive
derrière évidemment le côté un peu
humoristique second degré que vous aviez
adopté dans dans ce roman c'est qu'on y
trouve déjà à la fois le féminisme et la
radicalité aussi et l'écologie parce que
il n'est pas dit dans l'extrait c'est
que il y a un fond écologique dans ce
dans ce roman policier radicalité
écologique c'était déjà en vous à
l'époque mais oui mais je pense mais ça
c'est vraiment marrant parce que
dans les critiques qu'on me fait il y a
beaucoup le fait que je sois de
opportuniste alors qu'en fait si vous
reprenez toutes mes déclarations et je
crois depuis 20 ou 30 ans je n'ai pas
bougé d'un IOT a c'est même peut-être un
sujet d'ailleurs mais je n'ai pas bougé
d'un yota ouais et alors quand on vous
entend dans cet extrait parler de
poupées vaudou on a clairement le
sentiment que l'écriture ça a été pour
vous une sorte d'exutoire à une forme de
colère et la colère vous l'assumez aussi
dans votre façon de faire de la
politique du coup est-ce que la
politique est une sorte d'exutoire pour
vous
non c'est pas un exutoire c'est plutôt
une manière en l'occurrence la politique
c'est plus une manière de gérer
aussi une forme d'angoisse sur le monde
dans lequel nous sommes c'est-à-dire que
moi je n'aime pas le monde dans lequel
nous sommes qui nous ont qui ne prend
aucun soin ni de la planète ni des gens
c'est pas pour évacuer un trop-plein de
quelque chose mais par contre la colère
c'est je l'utilise dans les émotions de
la politique parce que je trouve que ce
qui a tué la politique ces dernières
années c'est le fait qu'on ait face à
nous des espèces de gestionnaire froid
qui ont des tableaux Excel et qui nous
disent bah faut augmenter ça faut
diminuer ça et en fait ce qui me fait
lever le matin c'est précisément parce
que je ressens les choses et je pense
que ça doit être dit aussi et que ça
doit être un élément du débat politique
sinon il y a que la haine comme émotion
dans le débat politique et ça pour moi
c'est pas possible à l'époque de cette
archive vous n'étiez pas encore vraiment
engagé en politique vos vrais débuts ils
datent de 2009 vous vous présentez sur
la liste aux Européennes de d'Europe
écologie des verts puis aux régionales
vous devenez ensuite porte-parole
d'Europe Écologie mais vous n'avez pas
du tout la même façon de faire de la
politique qu'aujourd'hui c'était un peu
une autre Sandrine rousse comment est-ce
que vous la décriez cette Sandrine
Rousseau d'avant mais j'en bossais
beaucoup plus les codes de la politique
en fait bon déjà le fond était quand
même le même si j'ai pas bouger
là-dessus mais
mais je endossais plus les codes de la
police oui j'étais plus conformiste et
j'étais plus je me comportais plus de la
manière dont on attend que quelqu'un en
politique se comporte et en fait ça je
l'ai fait complètement voler en éclat à
partir du moment où il y a eu cette
affaire Baupin j'imagine sur laquelle on
va revenir et où je me suis dit mais en
fait ce qu'on attend de nous ne sera
jamais convenable c'est-à-dire que de
toute façon notre place en politique
n'est jamais gagné notre place dans la
société n'est jamais gagnée donc allez
on va on va tout faire péter en fait
dans au moins dans le discours dans les
codes donc vous l'avez évoqué d'un mot
mais dans votre vie il y a un avant et
un après 2016 le 8 mars de cette année
là le député écologiste Denis Baupin a
posté un message
sur les réseaux sociaux avec une photo
de lui accompagnée de plusieurs autres
députés qui avaient tous du rouge à
lèvres et accompagné d'un message contre
les violences faites aux femmes quand
vous avez vu cela vous ça vous a mis un
peu hors de vous on peut le dire et avec
trois autres femmes vous avez déposé
plainte contre lui pour une raison très
simple on va écouter votre témoignage de
l'époque
j'étais à une tribune j'organisais une
réunion et un moment donné j'ai fait une
pause j'ai voulu aller aux toilettes et
dans le couloir
Denis Baupin m'a calé contre un mur et à
chercher à m'embrasser de force moi je
me revendique que féminisme je me
revendique comme celle qui justement se
parler j'ai en plus la possibilité de
parler c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que je
le fais aujourd'hui pour toutes les
femmes qui n'ont pas la possibilité de
le faire et pourtant même moi je ne l'ai
pas dit même moi alors vous féministe
vous n'avez pas
osé sur le coup en tout cas dénoncer
cette agression sexuelle cette prise de
conscience ça ça déclenché beaucoup de
choses chez vous déjà je l'avais dit
quand même à la direction d'Europe
Écologie et voilà en interne
oui mais en fait ça a été une prise de
conscience oui vraiment de plein de
choses déjà de
la violence à laquelle on s'exposait
quand on parlait ce que je n'avais pas
du tout anticipé mais vraiment vraiment
pas et puis de l'ampleur du phénomène
c'est-à-dire que là on est un an avant
demi-tour même un peu oui un an avant et
à ce moment là quand l'affaire Beaupain
sort qu'on est Hélène de Bosc Isabelle
Attar Annie la mer et moi quand on se
balade dans la rue quand on descend dans
la rue les femmes viennent nous voir et
nous disent moi aussi c'est ce que
j'écris dans un livre avant que Mewtwo
ne se déclenche et déjà le mot qui sort
c'est moi aussi et ça ça m'a frappé mais
ça a été pour moi une révélation totale
donc ça c'est le côté positif de ce que
vous appelez vous-même l'affaire
beaupaing il y a un côté quand même plus
négatif c'est que un an un peu plus d'un
an après vous jetez l'éponge vous
quittez la politique pourquoi est-ce que
c'est trop dur mais c'est trop dur du
coup mais ça a été d'une dureté inouïe
inouïe ce qu'on s'est pris dans la tête
et puis le fait que cette parole n'était
pas acceptée et tout d'ailleurs mon ami
un pied à terre vraiment parce qu'on y
arrivait plus donc moi je me suis arrêté
je me suis dit que je j'allais faire
autrement avancer les choses j'ai créé
une association qui s'appelait parler et
qui a permis à plein de femmes de de
prendre conscience de plein de choses de
parole de parole victimes de violences
sexuelles et qu'entre nous c'est Hersant
sa chance en relation descendante juste
entre nous à égalité et puis au bout
d'un moment je me suis dit voilà on peut
pas non plus dire aux femmes de parler
et leur montrer qu'en fait parler remet
tout en cause quoi donc il fallait que
je revienne donc vous êtes revenus en
politique à partir de 2020 mais j'ai
l'impression que votre vrai come-back si
on peut dire c'est à l'été 2021
université d'été d'Europe Écologie Les
Verts vous portez candidate à la
primaire des écologistes pour la
présidentielle et là c'est une nouvelle
Sandrine Rousseau qui est apparue
nouvelle déjà avec un nouveau logiciel
politique l'éco féminisme est-ce que
vous pouvez déjà nous définir parce que
tout le monde connaît pas les
coféministes en quelques mots juste pour
comprendre ce que c'est pas l'éco
féminisme c'est de dire qu'à partir du
moment où vous estimez que l'autre n'est
là que à votre service et que vous
pouvez l'utiliser le prendre et le jeter
autant qu'il est possible de le faire
simplement parce que vous faites du
profit et bien vous le faites des gens
comme le fait de la planète à partir du
moment où le capitalisme est fondé sur
cela et bien sur cela qu'il nous faut
nous battre pour renverser complètement
les rapports le capitalisme mais aussi
le modèle patriarcal tout à fait et j'en
viens à ça justement l'éco féminisme
lui-même n'offre pas une vision très
positive de la masculinité ça peut
donner l'impression que vous mener un
combat politique contre les hommes et ça
c'est bien que vous me posiez la
question parce que c'est précisément pas
ça c'est à dire que en fait la société
est divisée autour de de valeur qui sont
mises du côté du masculin donc il y a la
valeur de conquête la valeur de
domination la valeur de d'être maître et
possesseur et tout ça mais tout ça c'est
une construction sociale et en fait les
hommes les humains les hommes ne sont
pas
ces critères là et il y a pas d'intérêt
à être un à être conquérant etc il y a
un intérêt à prendre soin à être à
égalité et à déconstruire tous ces tous
ces idées aussi en fait et on en vient à
cette fameuse phrase sur votre compagnon
vous vivez avec un homme déconstruit on
vous a beaucoup raillé caricaturer sur
cette phrase mais plus sérieusement
est-ce que vous êtes prêts de vous dans
la vie de tous les jours à accorder
votre confiance à un homme qui n'est pas
déconstruit
mais quelqu'un qui n'a pas réfléchi sur
les rapports de domination m'intéresse
pas tellement aujourd'hui en réalité
c'est à dire que
je pense qu'il a des impensés dans son
comportement qui mettent en danger les
autres en fait ce qui a changé chez vous
aussi chez la Sandrine Rousseau qu'on
découvre en 2021 c'est votre façon de
faire de la politique vous dites je pose
les pieds dans le plat c'est ma manière
d'être en politique sur le moment c'est
très violent mais après ça décante et on
avance un peu c'est comme ça que vous
arrivez à imposer vos thèmes dans le
débat public dans le débat médiatique il
y a eu des sondages d'opinion qui ont
été faits suite à ce que j'avais porté
dans le débat politique notamment sur le
barbecue sur la déconstruction sur les
tâches ménagères sur à chaque fois en
fait j'ai une majorité de Français qui
est d'accord avec moi sur le droit à la
paresse et donc c'est aussi ça qu'il
faut mesurer c'est que on est dans un
mouvement social qui aujourd'hui doit
être représentée dans le monde politique
et qu'il n'est pas suffisamment le 2
octobre 2022 dans l'émission C'est à
vous vous avez mis les pieds dans le
plat c'est le cas de le dire et ça a été
violent vous avez accusé le leader de
votre propre partie Julien Bayou d'avoir
eu je cite des comportements de nature à
briser la santé morale des femmes en
l'occurrence celle de son ancienne
petite amie qui a commis une tentative
de suicide après leur rupture et qui
sait confié directement à vous dans
cette affaire il n'y a pas eu de pleines
contre Julien Bayou la victime Allemagne
ne l'a pas accusé publiquement et les
faits que vous lui reprochez ne semble
pas relever d'une qualification pénale
est-ce que vous assumez la violence de
votre démarche politique dans cette
affaire est-ce que c'était une violence
nécessaire à quel point il a été
perçu comme violent le fait que je dise
juste que j'ai reçu une femme et que et
l'état dans lequel je l'ai vu parce que
j'ai vu une femme qui au moment où je
l'ai reçu qui n'allait vraiment pas bien
et donc qu'on dise aujourd'hui qu'on ose
dire qu'une femme ne va pas bien que ça
n'est pas normal et que ça doit nous
poser une question sur les rapports
humains et vérifier à tout le moins que
il n'y ait pas d'autres situations comme
ça à l'intérieur du parti par exemple et
bien
suscité un raz-de-marée et ça dit que
nous ne sommes pas prêts encore à ouvrir
ce champ des de ce que j'appelle les
violences psychologiques et qui sont
beaucoup de mal à être qualifiés
d'ailleurs par la justice la violence
elle s'exerce aussi contre vous vous
êtes régulièrement menacé de mort menacé
de viol notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux mais pas seulement vous c'est
violent vous la vivez au quotidien aussi
dans votre vie de tous les jours dans la
rue ça peut vous arriver alors c'est pas
tout le temps mais il y a des moments où
dans la rue oui ça devient compliqué
notamment par exemple au moment de
l'affaire Bayou ça devenait compliqué
dans la rue comment on vit avec ça
je vais pas vous dire qu'on vit
extrêmement bien mais
ça fait pour moi ça fait partie du du
combat politique et des intimidations
qu'on essaye d'avoir
sur le combat que je porte et ça n'est
pas négociable en fait on va passer à
notre quiz à présent si vous le voulez
bien je vous explique le principe je
vais commencer des phrases et ça va être
à vous de les compléter rapidement
on y va être une féministe à l'Assemblée
c'est un combat de tous les jours
vraiment compliqué
en arrivant dans l'hémicycle de voir à
quel point dès que je parlais il y avait
des huées et tout mais où on est où là
on n'est pas on n'est pas dans la fête
de
masculinisme enfin on est dans une
assemblée nationale et vraiment les
députés ne se sont pas toujours
comportés de manière correcte à ceux qui
me voient présidente en 2027 je réponds
qu'on est en 2023 vous dit pas pourquoi
pas je dis on est en 2023 et là on est
dans un dans les cinq camps qui viennent
ces cinq ans extrêmement important pour
la planète et je me battrai tous les
jours voilà je fais on verra en 2027 mai
2027 enfin je dois reconnaître que
Emmanuel Macron
je dois reconnaître que Manuel Macron
à une très haute opinion lui-même
vous en sortez bien vous n'avez pas à
dire du bien de lui c'est vraiment rien
positif
parce que non vraiment pas vraiment
vraiment pas merci beaucoup Sandrine
Rousseau d'être venu dans la politique
et moi merci
[Musique]